how's go murres my name welcome back oh
you're saying in my ass
welcome back to part three out of five
hundred and ninety six of goat simulator
so we have yet to sacrifice for a
greater purpose best from beliefs all
the front flips haha this is how you
properly sit on the bench okay so we
need to sacrifice five of them to Satan
I mean to gather the sacrifices Armand
that's the developer of the game define
my top oh sure he came with me I got
damnit when I say you get sacrifice to
the spawn of Satan you do it okay wait
am I missing one no it is Oh what the
[ __ ]
Oh hail the giant goat oh god what the
[ __ ] blood fruit are for demonic power
where am I what the [ __ ]
what just happen this model make you
look fierce as [ __ ] I don't [ __ ] sway
join me peasant the [ __ ] it's raining
goats hallelujah what you're crying be
happy that's better
peg oh geez
ha ha ha ha what is happening what do I
do
oh my god I'm sad that's Jiki ha ha ha I
was like why is he blue that doesn't
make any sense
[ __ ] glorious [ __ ] man this is game
of the [ __ ] year gotta go some fights
my mother [ __ ] oh Jesus
star by that oh I'm so [ __ ] kawaii -
alright so let's go inside here cuz I
want it why why won't you let me go
inside oh here's the house here's house
ok yeah what up work hard are you lazy
[ __ ]
see how plug in this game is that's
basically every time I nope in front of
the computer
I was told there was something cool up
here [ __ ] lying
that is pretty sexy man let me help you
that's way better I'm gonna get goat
mares flappy goat what the [ __ ] no can I
play are too flat oh okay
oh come on ah Jays oh he's playing it
and leaves in the other [ __ ] flappy
bird games you don't have to stare the
goat ass this is way better
yes oh the flat master I am the fab the
flat man whatever so gay guys did you
see that did you [ __ ] say that [ __ ]
this is good is he farting to get
quicker I do that too actually it's a
little secret of mine
oh there's one here too it's a goat
Stefano never noticed before
let's make ourself tall and blue oh I'm
so cool oh geez I love the giraffe so
much your wife is like my this is like
my spirit animal
hahahaha [ __ ] I need to get in here so
it's a problem for me almost there
nailed it alright now I need to lick
that it's my help of God help me pouch
oh no no no no no no no oh
ha ha oh ha ha ha nail that gonna have
to make our self a little tinier I don't
know what's going on
but I know he's in pain [ __ ] just
want to go inside man there it is there
it is let me lick it
just like the beat I got it well what is
happening what is happening they call me
that goes Lords above it must be my
torquing that attracted them yes
country roads to the plains where oblong
oh I'm shut down baby I mean space rig
traffic hitting dead nice I want to go
home now
what the hell Oh Jason I'm fine
Oh let it go you so random Johnny fire
what are you doing oh god oh god no
Jennifer please I'm sorry you're
beautiful oh no Jennifer not the poor
humans oh well ha ha did anyone come on
I got a kid at least kill one of them
guys [ __ ] sake
stop being a goddamn happy
there you go that's way better this is
Katamari gold edition you're my best
friend forever I love you Jennifer data
fire her heart is just made of stone
Jesus its took forever but I did it why
my hair cut burning did I change did I
get a haircut did I do that all that
become goat JB god damn it it's true oh
no I'm a redhead why do I have butts on
my head let me get that let me get that
boom feather goat what the [ __ ] is the
fat ago is that a bird yeah Oh Jay says
my neck
so fabulous hello how are you walks oh
geez
so awesome try the goat best go feather
go the best gun alright I should be able
to do this achievement pretty easily
then oh geez
uh uh uh uh uh uh uh
yes alright alright alright alright
there's five of them
oh geez oh geez oh geez it's harder to
control than I buy - oh God oh god no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no you further a little [ __ ] front
flap flap flap how I oh [ __ ]
oh that [ __ ] neck man you thought I
was a goat no must make ah know what has
happened
hahahahaha oh [ __ ] oh god can actually
do it that was for how the [ __ ] is that
five
I got dab it out oh I'm fine
there's something very sexual about this
I can't really explain it I'm hung like
a horse what happens if I that's tiny
oh god that's disturbing you thought it
was a goat
no I'm spaghetti alright and the next
one we'll try and find all that goats I
hope you guys enjoyed this episode maybe
like potato helps me out a lot I really
appreciate it it's Skycar birthday see
you bros tomorrow my bow